We’ve been using the 2018 iPad Pro since
it came out almost a year and a half ago,
and one thing’s for certain..
It’s been through a lot!
So let’s examine the history of this iPad
Pro and how our personal thoughts on it have
changed as software has evolved and brought
us into 2020.
Now we are expecting a new 2020 iPad Pro within
the next couple of months, which we discuss
in that video which you can check out after
this one, but I personally believe the 2018
model is gonna sell like hotcakes even after
the 2020 model comes out….
Let’s talk about why.
There are 5 main features of this iPad Pro
that greatly added to its success and they’re
also the features that really matter for 2020
and beyond!
But before I get into those features, I want
to quickly go through how this iPad Pro has
evolved since release.
In my first review of the 2018 iPad Pro, less
than two weeks after release, my thoughts
were mostly negative.
I mentioned that it was a mistake for Apple
to market the iPad Pro as a computer replacement
when the software was so limiting.
Even though they added the USB-C port, you
couldn’t connect a flash drive or an external
storage drive.
File imports were limited to photos only using
a SD card adapter, and it forced you to use
the Photos app to do it.
They also added external display support,
but it basically only mirrored your display
so you still had to touch your iPad to control
it because at the time, there was no mouse
support.
The 11” model also had a new aspect ratio
which meant that most apps and games couldn’t
use up the full display until they were updated
to specifically support it.
And in terms of performance, even though the
2018 iPad Pro is much faster than the 2017
model, they both felt exactly the same because
there were barely any apps that could utilize
its full power.
So basically, when this iPad Pro was released,
it honestly wasn’t really worth buying.
And then came iPadOS, which completely changed
the game.
External drives now work perfectly fine, allowing
you to freely drag and drop files to and from
the iPad Pro.
You can even edit photos and videos directly
off of a drive without having to first import
it onto your iPads local storage.
Not only that, but you can now log onto a
storage server wirelessly using SMB.
We did this ourselves and were able to easily
access the files on our server.
Apple updated split-view so that you can now
open two instances of the same app right next
to each other, making it a whole lot more
useful.
Alongside that, they added new gestures for
text selection and undoing mistakes which
make it easier to use.
Safari added a new Downloads folder feature,
allowing you to download PDFs and other files
off the internet and quickly use and edit
them.
Apple even added full keyboard shortcut support
so that using your iPads smart keyboard actually
felt like using a MacBook.
A huge bonus for artists and Apple pencil
users was that the Pencil’s latency was
reduced from 20ms to only 9, which make it
feel even more like a real pencil.
Along with that, Apple finally added mouse
support.
Now while it’s not perfect, and it works
similarly to how touch controls work, allowing
you to set your iPad aside using it with an
external display
Those new iPadOS features changed everything
about the iPad Pro, and it started to make
us question whether it could actually replace
a laptop, so we compared them to last year’s
base MacBook Air and MacBook Pro.
Our conclusion was that for the first time
ever, the iPad Pro actually makes a lot of
sense to buy compared to a laptop.
It’s got tons of power, an excellent display,
great battery life, great portability, and
it’s actually very functional with the new
iPad OS features, giving you awesome multitasking
and file management capabilities while also
giving you access to the massive database
of iOS apps and games.
And then came MacOS Catalina, which allowed
users to connect their Mac to their iPad Pro
using the new SideCar feature for things like
art and productivity.
So now, here we are in 2020, and the great
news is that since the release of iPadOS,
the 2018 iPad Pro has continued to get better
and better.
Now, almost all apps that we’ve tried support
the new aspect ratio perfectly.
New apps like the full desktop version of
Photoshop are now available and they do a
great job of supporting the iPad Pro, like
for example, supporting the second generation
Apple Pencil’s new double-tap feature.
We’ve notice that there are more and more
apps and games are now utilizing more of the
iPad Pro’s immense performance, allowing
users to really feel the extra power.
Not only that, but there are now more games
that support the iPad Pro’s 120Hz display,
like Fortnite, which recently added 120 FPS
support to the 2018 iPad Pro, and let me tell
you, it works incredibly well.
So while it seemed ridiculous at launch that
Apple packed in so much power into this iPad
Pro, we’re actually extremely glad that
they did because it’s still very powerful
even with the latest apps and games that are
being released.
Just recently, Microsoft outlook finally added
the long-awaited side-by-side multitasking
support, so you can have two of the same microsoft
app open side by side.
And if you look on Amazon, you’ll see a
bunch of USB-C docks for the iPad Pro, really
giving users more freedom to connect whatever
devices they’d like to.
Companies like Brydge are now coming out with
iPad Pro keyboards that feature trackpads
to make them more and more like actual MacBooks,
and if Apple decides to add cursor support
to a future iPadOS update, these new keyboards
will be incredibly useful.
Now that we know how drastically the iPad
Pro has evolved since its release, let’s
get into the 5 main features that I think
really matter for 2020 and beyond.
First off, the main feature that really sets
the 2018 iPad Pro apart is the design.
The square-edges and slate shape make it really
unique compared to any other iPad.
It’s also the only iPad to get rid of the
home button and switch to Face ID, giving
us a display with even bezels and rounded
corners.
This makes using this iPad Pro a whole different
experience compared to using any other iPad,
and that is what really matters going into
2020.
And if the rumors are true of the 2020 iPhones
coming with a new square-edged design, the
2018 iPad Pro is going to feel perfectly at
home and not outdated at all.
The second main feature that really matters
is the performance.
Even though the new iPhone 11 Pro is using
the latest Apple chip, it’s actually still
slower than the iPad Pro in both processor
and graphics performance.
The performance is so high that even after
a year and a half, it can easily chew through
any app or game on the app store without any
performance issues, so that gives us consumers
a lot of confidence going into 2020, knowing
that we can truly rely on this iPad Pro.
The third main feature is the display.
While most of the new higher-end iPads come
with the same Retina quality displays, very
low reflectivity and excellent touch support,
the iPad Pro gets a major advantage.
And I’m not talking about the brighter 600
nit display compared to 500 on the others,
but I’m talking about the fact that the
iPad Pro gets the incredible 120hz ProMotion
technology.
This basically means that the display can
dynamically adjust it’s own refresh rate
between 24hz and 120hz based on the content
you’re viewing.
So if you’re watching a movie, the display
refreshes at 24hz which will save battery
life.
And if you’re on the home screen or playing
a game with 120FPS support, you’re getting
super fluid animations that you just can’t
get on any other iPad, tablet, or even MacBook!
And seeing as more apps and games are starting
to support 120FPS, this ProMotion feature
is going to get even better going into 2020
and beyond!
Now the fourth feature is actually the USB-C
port.
Unlike any other iPad, the 2018 iPad Pro is
able to easily connect to an external display
using USB-C. You can also buy a USB-C dock
and get access to a bunch of ports that you
can’t get on a regular iPad.
And what’s special about USB-C is that it’s
able to supply power to external flash drives
and storage drives, allowing you to easily
transfer files, which is much more complicated
on a Lightning-packing iPad.
Having this USB-C port makes this 2018 iPad
Pro much more capable going into 2020, and
it’s gonna allow it to compete with the
upcoming iPad Pro refresh much easier than
if it was still packing a Lightning port.
Now, finally onto the 5th main feature, which
admittedly, isn’t really a feature..
But it’s still a big deal, and that’s
the price!
We’ve seen this iPad Pro go as low as $675
on Amazon.
That’s a whole $125 off retail price.
And in a couple of months when the new model
comes out, there’s a possibility that it
could drop even lower, maybe as low as 600-625
dollars brand new.
And at that price, you’re seriously getting
so much bang for your buck.
We’re talking an iPad that’s so good that
it competes with laptops, so I can imagine
every 2018 iPad Pro getting snatched up off
Amazon as the new 2020 model comes out, because
it’s still going to be that good, going
into 2020 and beyond.
So there you guys have it, that’s our review
of the 2018 iPad Pro in 2020.
If you enjoyed this video, you guys check
out our video of the iPad Pro playing Fortnite
at 120 frames per second, and if you’re
not already subscribed, you can click that
circle above so you don’t miss out on our
2020 iPad Pro coverage when it gets released.
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next one!